as coronavirus deaths across the globe
hit more than 230,000 while the Trump
administration is making efforts now to
hold China accountable according to the
Washington Post senior officials across
multiple government agencies were
meeting today to quote begin mapping out
a strategy for seeking retaliatory
measures against China what that mean
trumpet aides have discussed stripping
China of its sovereign immunity aiming
to enable the United States government
or victims to sue China for damages a
top Chinese official yesterday refused
though to accept responsibility imposed
two months for reparations from China
are not reasonable and they have no
legal basis and in fact I think there is
no difference between such demands and
blackmail now is nikki Haley former US
ambassador to the UN and of course
former governor of South Carolina
ambassador Haley first of all it's great
to have you on the show we really
appreciate it tonight
he said blackmail ambassador Haley what
is your reaction to that this is what
the Chinese do this is what the two
years I was at the United Nations this
is what they do they basically will call
out others and do say things to others
but they don't want it said back to them
and you know the truth is the Chinese
are never gonna admit fault
they're never gonna admit that they did
anything wrong and that's why the United
States has to be smart we have to
strategically figure out how we're gonna
deal with China for the long term and
really make sure that we call them out
and let them know that we're on to them
what's the argument left at this point
ambassador Haley that we should not be
treating China the way we treated the
former Soviet Union where we basically
did very little trade we did very few
educational exchanges I was in one of
them so I know we just basically didn't
couple with them at all on key
initiatives so why shouldn't we treat
China the same way so we absolutely
should treat China the same way this is
about the fact that China is our
number-one national security threat they
are increasing their military and that
needs to put our military on notice
they've been stealing intellectual
property from the very beginning and the
president needs to hold firm that if
they do it we put sanctions and tariffs
back on them they have created a
surveillance state literally there
people don't know what's going on in the
rest of the world unless China approves
it they have a million minorities in
concentration camps making them change
their names change their religion and
the way they do things
ambassador Halley today the Director of
National Intelligence confirmed that the
u.s. does believe kovat 19 could have
been the result of an accident at a lab
in Wuhan President Trump said he's seen
convincing evidence of the same but then
the New York Times seems concerned about
this any American intelligence report
blaming a Chinese institution and
officials for the outbreak could
significantly harm relations with China
for years to come so the New York Times
is worried about our relationship with
China when all these Americans have died
and 30 million Americans are out of work
because of this virus ambassador what
about the Chinese relationship when
Taiwan came out December 30th and said
they saw a person-to-person contact in
terms of Kovan where was China when the
World Health Organization asked
questions on the 14th and they stalled
where was China even up until the 30th
of January where they didn't want us to
stop trade they knew what was happening
and they didn't tell us the president
today ambassador Halley said he's going
to walk a fine line he says he thinks
try China has tried to be transparent do
you agree with that China doesn't know
how to be transparent there and all they
want is what they want the rest of the
world to see they their perception is
everything if I ever wanted to get under
China's skin all I did was call them out
because they can't stand to be called
out they want to create the narrative
and they take on the approach that if
they say it's true then the rest of the
world will believe it they do not know
what transparency is and that will never
happen in communist China